with the next generation of internet
exchanges focused on maximum privacy and
security a variety of ways have been
enforced to maintain them as such
censorship has been shifted from the
streets to the digital domain forces the
standard citizen to derive alternative
ways to maintain anonymity major weapon
in this battle for privacy and security
is the tor browser an independent
browser meant to browse the internet
while reeling information through the
tor network it serves as a meaningful
alternative to the standard internet
browsing habits to better understand the
purpose of this browser and such we must
learn about the work of the tor network
featuring its own routing protocol the
top browser is an easy way to maintain
anonymity while browsing without
emptying one's wallet
let's take a look at the topics to be
covered today
we start at the explanation of what is
the tor network and its significance in
the working of the top browser
we take a look at the onion routing
protocol and how it transmits the data
from the client devices to the tor
directories in order to circumvent
government censorship
moving on we learn a few features of the
tor browser and the distinct advantages
the tor network provides
next we learn the difference between
using a vpn and a tor to anonymize
internet usage and finally we have a
live demonstration of the tor browser
anonymization features in action
let's move on to learning about the tor
network
tor shot for the onion router it's an
open source privacy network that permits
users to browse the web anonymously the
tor was initially developed and solely
used by the u.s navy to protect
sensitive government communications
before the network was made publicly
available the digital era has disrupted
the traditional way of doing things in
every sector of the economy the rapid
rise in development and innovation of
digital products has given way to
frequent data breaches and cyber thefts
in response consumers are increasingly
opting for products that offer data
privacy and cyber security
tor is one such underground network that
was implemented for the purpose of
protecting users identities the tor
network is one example of the many
emerging technologies that attempt to
fill a data privacy void in a digital
space plagued by cyber security concerns
the tor network intercepts the traffic
from your browser and bounces a user's
request of a random number of other user
ip addresses
then the data is passed to the user
requester final destination
these random users are volunteer devices
which are called as nodes or relays
the tor network disguises your identity
by encrypting the traffic and moving it
across different tower relays within the
network
the tor network uses an onion routing
technique for transmitting data hence
the original name of onion router
to operate within the tor network a user
has to install the tor browser any
address or information requested using
the browser is transmitted through the
tor network it has its own feature set
which we will be covering over later in
this video
as we discussed already the data passing
through the tor network must follow a
unique protocol known as the onion
routing protocol let us learn more about
its unique characteristics
in our normal network usage the data is
transmitted directly
the sender has data packets to transmit
which is done directly over a line of
communication with either a receiving
party or a server of some kind
however since the data can easily be
captured while being transmitted the
security of this exchange is not very
reliable moreover it becomes very easy
to trace the origin of such requests on
many occasions websites with
questionable and controversial content
are blocked from the isp this is
possible since the isp is able to detect
and spy on user information passing
through the network
apart from isps there is a steady chance
of your private information being
intercepted by hackers
unfortunately easy detection of the
source and contents of a web request
make entire network extremely vulnerable
for people who seek anonymity over the
internet
however in the onion routing protocol
things take a longer route we have a
sender with the top browser installed on
the client system the network sends the
information to node one's ip address
which encrypts the information and
passes it on to node 2's address which
performs another encryption and passes
it on to node 3 address
this is the last address which is also
known as the exit node
this last node decrypts the encrypted
data and finally relays the request to
the final destination which can be
another device or a server end
this final address thinks the request
came from the exit node and grants
access to it the encryption process
across multiple computers repeats itself
from the exit node to the original user
the tor network obfuscates user ip
addresses from unwanted surveillance by
keeping the user's request untraceable
with multiple servers touching the data
it makes the tracking very difficult for
both isps and malicious attackers
now that we understand the way tor works
let us learn more about the tor browser
the top browser was developed by a
non-profit organization as a part of the
tor project in 2008 and its first public
release was announced
the tor browser is a browser forked from
the popular firefox that anonymizes your
web traffic using the tor network
if you are investigating a competitor
researching an opposing litigant in a
legal dispute or just think it's creepy
for your isp or the government to know
what websites you visit the top browser
might be the right solution
before the top browser were developed
using that network to maintain anonymity
was a huge task for everyday consumers
starting from the setup to the usage the
entire process demanded a lot of
knowledge and practice the top browser
managed to make it easy for users to
traverse the relay server center and
guarantee the privacy of the data
exchange
a major feature of the tor browser is
the ability to delete all browser
history cookies and tracking data the
moment it is closed
every new launch of the browser opens an
empty slate having a usage habits from
being tracked and singled out
a major feature that is the highlight of
the tor network is the availability of
onion links
only a small portion of the world wide
web is available to the general public
we have the deep web that contains links
that are not allowed to be indexed by
standard search engines like google and
bing
the dark web is a further subset of the
deep web which contains onion links
tor browser gives you access to these
dot onion websites which are only
available within the tor network
onion is a special used top-level domain
which designates an anonymous onion
service which is also known as a hidden
service similar to the links of the deep
web these onion links provide services
like online shopping cryptocurrency and
many other products not available in the
consumer internet space
often being considered as a haven for
illegal activities and sales anya links
provide both information and assets in a
private manner without the risk of
spying by authorities
browsing the web over tor is slower than
the clear net due to the multiple layers
of encryption
some web services also blocked our users
door browser is also illegal in
authoritarian regimes that want to
prevent citizens from reading publishing
and communicating anonymously
journalists and dissidents around the
world have embraced store as a
cornerstone of democracy and researchers
are hard at work at improving tor's
anonymity properties
let us take a look at some of the
advantages of using the tor browser over
standard web browsers
the highlight of using the tor browser
is to maintain anonymity over the
internet the cause for such requests can
differ from person to person but all of
these concerns are answered by the tor
network doubting the information via
multiple nodes and relay servers make it
entirely difficult for the isp to keep a
track of usage data
the entire top project is designed to be
completely free and open source
allowing the code for the browser to be
inspected and audited by third parties
helps in the early detection of faulty
configurations and critical bugs it is
present for multiple operating system
starting from laptops to mobile devices
a number of websites are blocked by
governments for a variety of reasons
journalists under authoritarian regimes
have difficulty in getting the word out
regarding the situation
since the onion routing protocol
transfers data between multiple servers
of random countries the domains being
blocked become available when used via
tor
usage of these encryption messaging
platforms is easily enforced using the
tor browser which otherwise would have
been a difficult task under oppressive
circumstances
many people believe that a vpn offers
the same benefits as the top browser
let's put both of them to the test and
see the differences between them
coming to the first point of difference
tor is completely free and open source
all of the code for the browser and the
network can be audited and has been
cleared for security concerns
when it comes to vpn there are many
different brands which have open source
clients but the same cannot be said for
their counterparts some have partly open
source while some have completely locked
up their code so that they cannot be
stolen further
moving on tower has multiple relay
points in its data transfer protocol
between the server and the receiver
there are three different ip nodes that
number can increase but it will always
be more than two
once the data is passed from the
cylinder it goes through all of those
delay points while in the case of a vpn
the connection is made from the client
device to the vpn server and then to the
requested destination there is no other
ip node that comes in to work here
thereby making the connection a
one-to-one between the client and a vpn
as a next point since store handles
multiple layers of encryption and the
data passes through multiple systems
along the way the performance is slow
compared to a vpn where the performance
is relatively fast due to the less
number of nodes the data passes through
similarly the multi-layer encryption of
tor is consistent if you use tor browser
every single request passes through the
same layer of encryption and follows the
same routing protocol
in the case of a vpn different companies
offer different levels of encryption
some have multi-hop some prefer a single
one-to-one connection and these kind of
differences make the choice much more
variable
finally the nodes and relays being used
in the tor network are volunteer there
is no company holding over them so
jurisdiction becomes relatively
straightforward whereas in the case of
vpns many such vpns are hosted by adware
companies or are being monitored by
central governments to note the usage
information
now that we have a better understanding
of the tor browser and its routing let
us take a look at how the tor browser
can anonymize and protect our internet
usage
on opening up the tor browser for the
first time this is the page that you are
going to be welcomed with we have the
option of connecting to the tor network
before we start our browsing
so let's press connect
and we can see that it is connected
coming to the anonymization
let's check my current location on
google chrome
currently is showing as navi mumbai in
maharashtra
if we check the same link on the tor
browser we should get a different
address
now every link that we open in the tor
browser will be little delayed and the
speed will be hampered because of the
multiple layers of encryption like we
discussed now as you can see
it's showing a german ip and the state
of bavaria
this is how the anonymization works
there is no vpn configured there is no
proxy attached it's straight up this out
of the box settings that come inbuilt
with the tor browser
similarly we have an option of cleaning
up the data
let's say if you want to refresh your
location and you want to use a different
id for the next browsing session
if you just restart it once
and you can have to check it again
we should be seeing a different country
this time
as you can see we have netherlands right
now so this is how you can keep
refreshing your address you can keep
refreshing your host location so that it
cannot be tracked when in browsing the
internet
like we discussed we have some onion
links that can only be used on the tor
network
as you can see these kind of links do
not open in the google chrome browser
but once we copy these over to the tor
browser
as you can see we have opened the hidden
wiki which is available only on the tor
network
this is kind of an alternative wikipedia
website where we can find articles to
read and more information to learn
similarly we have another onion link
over here
which is once again available only for
the tall browser
now these kind of delays are expected
but they are a valid compromise because
they maintain the anonymity that many
people desire
similarly we have found a hidden wallet
which is a cryptocurrency wallet which
is specifically for dark web members
this operates over the tor network and
this is used by mostly journalists and
people who want to anonymize their
internet transactions when it comes to
dealing money
all of the transactions that occur over
the tor network are almost impossible to
track therefore these kind of
cryptocurrency wallets are very big on
the deep web this is just one example
while having multiple different wallets
for every single cryptocurrency
available
with this we have reached the end of our
lesson on the top browser hope you
learned something new today if you have
any questions regarding this topic feel
free to write them down in the comments
section and we will get back to you as
soon as possible thank you for watching
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here